brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza
but then just imagine this amazing D
that you want to do but we turn it into
a money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
every single time the money generated
from that W that building is going to go
to our Palestinian brothers and sisters
for the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150
years and this will be a form of
true click the link below and donate may
Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends Starbucks has lost 11 billion PS
we know that we are doing the boycot ald
it's going well carry on don't give up
inshah now strangely enough they have
put a job description they are looking
for employees what kind of employees
let's go through inshallah so the
project name is Starbucks
understood Casting Company is DB casting
project type print shoot dates January
11 18th 2024 to January 17th 2024
nonunion 300 a session not bad at all
250 buyout includes of agent fee looking
for anyone who is a hijabi or is head
covering view the role why is Starbucks
all of a sudden has interest in hijabis
do they want to do a hijab tutorial do
they want to do a turban tutorial what
do they want to do well it's very what
they want to do they want to realize
they've realized that they've lost great
amount of money 11
billion and they are thinking you know
what we need to if we get a person in a
hijab working then maybe Muslims the
muslamic the Muslims can start buying
more coffee no we don't care if you had
the Imam of wherever working there we
are not going to come there we don't
care if you did East celebrations or not
only that if you open the Starbucks
Masjid we're still not going to come
it's as simple as that whatever you do
desperate times call for desperate
measures and it is very clear brother
sisters boycott works so for those
people who were saying you know live
your life they can live their lives
carry on boycotting boycott clearly
clearly works brothers and sisters carry
on the boycott do not stop there are
many many other ways you can you can um
have find Alternatives so brothers and
sisters please carry that on number one
boycott number two post about what's
happening number three make Dua number
four pray your Salah Allah's Right comes
what way before anyone for that matter
the Palestinians or whoever is for that
matter yes Allah subhana T's Right comes
I'm not saying you don't talk about that
you do but Allah's rights you should be
more worried about and number five there
is a link for the W that we are trying
to raise and buy a building that will
generate income to help the Palestinian
cause rebuilding those homes uh the food
and also activism alhamdulillah so
please please donate to that that's all
I have to say to next time brother
sisters maybe some sisters can apply and
see what they're really about but you
know what forget it they are hurt
brother and sisters we don't care if
they put hijab on their cups we are not
coming
there